[Music]
[Music]
thank you
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy we find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes I'm joined by my
co-host Dr Greg Sadler and today we're
talking about why taking down time is
important for us as human beings and
particularly in the you know time and
era that we're in and I don't just mean
like you know the grand historical sweep
of late capitalism and all that I we're
also recording this at a time in between
holidays Thanksgiving is has passed with
all of the stuff that that entails we've
got the other holidays coming up you
know at the end of the year and it could
be I think kind of useful for us to
remind ourselves of the need to take
some down time for ourselves and and
there's a lot of ways of looking at
downtime some of which I'm going to say
this a little bit funnily are more
productive than others because you know
if it's real downtime we shouldn't be
focusing on being productive but there's
some that are uh better better suited to
us than than others and so what we're
going to try to do here is a pretty
freewheeling conversation that's looking
into the downtime that we do take and
how we can have better downtime or more
thoughtful or deliberate downtime and
we're also going to talk about what
stands in the way of it and I pitched
this idea to Dan in part because I heard
something on NPR a while back that I
thought was kind of
provocative so and it was actually over
the Thanksgiving break I was driving
along and I was listening to uh one of
those those shows and they had this
Swedish philosopher Lars svenden boy you
can't get a more Swedish name than that
and he works on the topic of burnout and
one of the things that he said that I
thought was really interesting he said
my dangerous idea is that work isn't
what's wearing us out these days but our
Leisure Time in fact we've never worked
less than we do today most people are
actually happy with their work even
though they believe that work in general
is getting harder but their own work
isn't getting harder and we sleep less
than we used to but whatever we're
spending that time on it's not work so
really what is wearing us out what is
making us burnt out it's really our
leisure time and when I heard that I
like I think a lot of Americans had the
response of wow it must be nice to be in
Sweden where we're working less and the
you know the work isn't what we're
finding onerous or you know burning us
out or anything because I don't think
that's the case for for a lot of
Americans so we're going to talk about
that in a bit but I did think that his
his remark that our Leisure Time
is
not really that relaxing it's not it's
not conducive to to downtime or to to
refreshing ourselves maybe there's
something to that I think and so I
thought that would be a good jumping off
point to explore but we have a
Counterpoint as well Dan's gonna lead
you into to this
yeah so um
uh
well he has an interesting idea there is
something from a recent post on Reddit
from the
um anti-work subreddit making the rounds
uh quote I met this guy in uni and since
graduating he's been living the life he
got up at 5am to work out and do all
life's admin then worked 8 30 to 1930 or
7 30 in the afternoon every day in
finance for about 150k a year and then
would spend his evenings working on a
side hustle business on weekends he'd do
voluntary management work for a charity
he had Financial Independence and he was
going to retire early the world was his
oyster and he would travel around the
world to every country with a laptop I'd
never left Europe and got very envious
of this but he said but the sad reality
is he's been a zombie for over a decade
now he never got more than five hours
sleep he never ate healthy food he
didn't have romantic relationships and
found
would have never found time for friends
and he was always cutting costs to save
for retirement he'd have cheaper longer
flights with many changes and dump his
bags at a hostel before getting to work
on zero sleep he never got to explore
the places he was in it was always just
another office I'd only see him once
every three months or so and even when
he was living in his house 20 minute
walk away from me and whenever I saw him
he'd be too exhausted to do any
activities we just go to the pub where
he switched off an hour and his biggest
regret was taking up smoking which he
did to network with managers on smoke
breaks at a previous job
and then found quite impossible to quit
my last conversation was with him was
about work I said that I'd get an extra
five days annual leave because I've
worked here five years now he said it's
not worth it I'd be better off switching
jobs get a pay raise and then take
unpaid time off to return to my previous
salary I'm going to take those five days
five days off to spend with my family
and think about my good times I had with
old friends I found out about his death
when the hospital called me he kept my
phone number in his wallet as an
emergency contact I didn't know this
until I got the call I didn't realize I
was the closest person he had in the
world to me he felt like a distant
friend who I only got to hang out with a
few times a year
yeah that's quite a story isn't it I
mean right it's not quite Ebenezer
screws Scrooge level of miserness or
whatever we call it it's not I guess it
is kind of misery but a miser whatever
it is that that they're up to but this
guy's doing it instead not so much with
just money but with his time and
attachments and connections
and I think these are you know these are
kind of two sides of the story on the
one hand we've got this Swedish
philosopher who's saying oh you know
it's not the work that's the problem
it's not knowing what to do with our
leisure time and then we've got this guy
who I think we know people like this
right who are constantly hustling they
seem to have all of their priorities in
order but something goes drastically
wrong and they don't enjoy their their
life what do you mean that I I shouldn't
be out there on on Christmas day uh you
know picking up an Uber ride uh what
what is this there's money on the table
just leaving it there what's wrong with
you Greg you know Uber is an interesting
one because a few years back
um when we were in between various money
making activities uh we we knew some
friends who were driving for Uber and we
looked into possibly using one of our
cars for for ubering and we realized
when we started like poking around that
there wouldn't be a real gain in doing
it that we would be adding a lot of wear
and tear to our cars and you know taking
the the time that we have for other
things and spending it on driving people
around and maybe having random
conversations with strangers which could
be nice or could it could also be awful
depending on what kind of people they
are you know well you don't want to be
like the the Socrates uh of Uber driver
picks you up and starts like poking at
you I was like ah I don't know what is
it to have a good night you know there's
probably there's probably somebody out
there that would be perfectly suited to
that right and the good thing in in
philosophy is we we've got like a
division of labor we don't all have to
be Socrates we can we can do other
things instead but I mean what do you
make of these these two different Tales
yeah well the first thing I want to say
is or you could be like the diogenes of
uber and you pull up and you flash your
it writes to them and says I'm looking
for a good man also needs a ride
um but uh okay so the the first one here
is interesting
because this is
um
definitely a a question of what what
makes good downtime or Leisure we are in
such a connected world that the in one
way that we fail at this is to be
constantly
berated by you know our dings and our
whistles of our little skitter boxes
that we all carry in our pocket yeah and
uh and Skinner box is a a device used in
uh what psychology or is it um it was
psychology and it was uh the behaviorist
school that Skinner was was particularly
associated with BF Skinner I believe
yeah exactly yeah okay uh basically it
was a
box that would give you rewards for
hitting the button
um and we basically turned our phones
into that with all their apps that like
Ding and beep at you also you see these
a lot in um
casinos they're designed to get you to
keep on pulling that lever all those
flashing lights you know you could just
be a winner it's one more pull away
and so um to finish my thought here um
we have this you know this constantly
connected way of interacting with the
world that has resulted in us
um
not having really good Leisure
um as well as you know uh especially
within you know when we're so far away
from our families if you're living alone
or something that there there's
definitely something about
um
doing this thing on your own uh and
relaxing with your with on your own
instead of like with people in a very
supportive place and then the other side
here we were talking about this guy
who's is working out that you know um
his entire life is just hustling and you
know I guess good for him but you're
optimizing
um for only one thing in your life and
um you're you're sacrificing the rest of
your life for it I don't feel like
that's a really good way to lead your
life and and as it says you know uh at
the end of here he dies at like you know
what rather young age it seems yeah
um you never know when your life is
going to come to an end
um and because of this there's not
always this guarantee that all these
plans you put into motion are actually
going to come to fruition
yeah I mean if you knew ahead of time
that you were going to die at 35 as
opposed to 85 I think there's a lot of
um sacrifices that we make a lot of
investments in time energy thought money
even Integrity where we would be like
nope not not really worth it you know
um but we don't know when we're going to
pass away unless unless we've been given
like a death sentence by the doctor or
something or we've committed some some
crime and like Socrates know that we're
going to die in a matter of time
drinking some Hemlock I mean for most of
us that's just not the case and we're
we're always sort of uh
making bets aren't we about the the
value of the things that we pass up or
we we pursue
um so you know I think that
in our society again let's go back to
the Swedish guy I don't think I mean
there are some people who really do
struggle with having so much leisure
time they have to figure out what to do
with it they're in a fortunate situation
as far as work but I don't think that's
the case for most of us in the present
Americans seem to be particularly driven
to work more and more and some of that
is
um you know because
jobs don't pay quite as well as they
ought to or we need to work to
accumulate the benefits that would
otherwise come from those if we look at
you know we compare ourselves to other
developed countries there's a lot of
things that are placed on us and
employers are are quite often trying to
get they're trying to squeeze as much as
they can out of their employees you know
to as we say do more with less and you
know that works for a while but
eventually people get get uh used up and
burned out I mean there are some people
who don't have enough work and then they
have to figure out what to do with their
time so that it's you know it's not a
they're not just simply wasting their
time they're not bored all the time or
engaging in Shallow activities that that
don't really contribute to their
happiness but I think most of us it's
it's a matter of we've got so much work
you know
uh that we have to
decide what to do well with our leisure
time and it's interesting that you
brought up like the casinos because
um so you know we go to the local casino
the Potawatomi to see bands because we
go to the Northern Lights Theater and
they have really you know some really
good bands that come in and it's you
know it's it I like it in part because
it's super easy to get in you park you
walk across you got to go down on the
casino floor where you see people
playing games and then you're in the
case you're in the the small theater and
you see the band and it's like five
minutes to get get out of there and go
back home
but a lot of uh things that we think are
going to be very relaxing going to other
concerts or like you know if you want to
go to a Packers game it's a big
production you know there's so much
involved in there
um you got to find parking and then like
take the Packers game thing if you go up
to Lambeau Field and you find parking
you're gonna walk for a long ways to get
there and then there's long lines to get
in and you watch the game if you you
know God forbid you should you know buy
something to eat or drink you know it's
gonna uh be quite a bit of money and
then you've got the long walk back out
perhaps having you know watched the team
lose and uh seeing all the people
unhappy about it and then you got to get
to your car and then you gotta like
figure out how to negotiate getting out
of the parking lot I mean it's it's a
huge ordeal in some respects and and
much of it is not all that relaxing and
and I think we could say that about so
many other things as well I mean
Thanksgiving holidays if you're the one
cooking that's not all that relaxing or
if you're the one cleaning it up or you
know you're stuck sitting next to the
proverbial crazy uncle that might not be
that cool either right so so a lot of
the questions have you ever been the
proverbial crazy uncle
well uh not in the sense of spouting
goofy conspiracy theories or anything
like that I was more Uncle Fun Time you
know uh the the one who would be uh you
know
um suggesting we play some games or
something like that you know listening
to the kids complain about their their
parents or their classmates or their
schools or stuff like that
um but I don't know I mean it doesn't
what's what's the distance between crazy
conspiracy theory uncle and Uncle fun
time I don't think there's a huge gap
you know so
yeah
um so this all kind of reminds me of you
know I guess I for the the Swedish large
here
um this latest philosopher uh that
I I you know I totally agree with him in
this the the bottom part that like the
what we do as Leisure can sometimes be
very not Leisure or full it can be
taxing right yeah but you know I think I
do agree with this this upper portion
especially depending on like where
you're working especially the United
States you know the first thing is that
we
um lionize uh you know work and
um you know basically avarice that you
know it's good to have money to make
money to
um all these things are Goods in and of
themselves and that's kind of like the
general cultural consensus which
um I think is really antithetical to
actually you know one making good
relationships because if all your
relationships are based on money then
what is the point of that relationship
it's not for the benefit of you and the
relationship and the person in it yeah
it's just for the the benefit of getting
stuff and or money and then the other
part of this is that like a lot of work
nowadays especially after you know the
work from home movement
as now we're constantly in contact with
our employers that there there's a
constant line of communication unless
you put up really strong walls
um you are going to be contacted
um on off working hours where the
working hours tend to just kind of blend
and you're never off you're always kind
of in this point and if you're
constantly in that moment then you
constantly have this little you know low
level amount of uh let's say stress that
uh is constantly pulling you to these
these thought patterns of yeah
work-oriented things and in order for us
to actually recover from our uh actual
work on a day-to-day we have to have a
time where we're not thinking about that
that's right and I and I think that
there's something else that could be
added on top of this
um actually two things so one is you're
right there's this always on phenomenon
uh you know it used to be that we were
on call like I used to work jobs right
have a pager or something like that but
I'd only be on call for a certain amount
of time and it wasn't what's a pager oh
yeah we should probably explain that for
the the younger crowd it was something
you could call right somebody would call
you and then like a little thing would
come up and the Really primitive ones
would just say the the phone number and
then you'd have to call that number and
this is before cell phones you'd have to
find a phone right uh and then some
would actually you could put in text and
they would say like you need to show up
here or something like that and you know
they were they were popular among people
who wanted to look important but they
were also like I had one when I was um
on security jobs and I was like the
shift Commander or stuff like that so
they would they would need to have the
pager so they could call me in or things
like that but now instead we have like
you know texts and emails and there's
this this expectation on the part of
many employers that employees should
make themselves available for all sorts
of things outside of regular work hours
and some employees are pushing back you
know which is which is I think to their
their credit but there's a kind of
pressure there well if I don't respond
then maybe they'll find another employee
who will be more amenable to this so
there's that aspect but I think a lot of
people also
because they've received these signals
let's call them or messages from all
sorts of people School parents uh
employers peers
they place these pressures upon
themselves that they need to constantly
be on the make as as we say right and I
don't think this is just with jobs and
money you could fall into this quite
easily with exercise programs and diet
and stuff like that oh if I'm going to
do the exercise program I need to do it
110 percent you know so I need to like
really get into this and I think people
could even do this with like fandoms or
Hobbies where they're one of the words
that you used optimizing a little bit
earlier right I think there's this this
strain of excessive optimizing that a
lot of people fall into and it could be
I mean it could be about your
relationships it could be a buy a whole
bunch of self-help books or you know
listen to podcasts about how to improve
your relationship and gonna have the
best relationship possible right
and a lot of these aiming at the best
um
it's just not very helpful as a matter
of fact I did a video recently because I
had somebody who had uh asked me
they they were concerned about their
philosophy reading and that they were
not making the best use of their their
spare time and reading you know becoming
very well read is how they put it and I
was like nobody's very well read even
the people you think are well read
aren't reading everything it's just
impossible these days and you can take
that pressure off of yourself that
you're placing on yourself making
yourself miserable by doing so so even
you know even philosophy can become a
trap in this respect for our own
expectations of our ourselves that you
know doing some downtime could it seems
scary to a lot of people I think to do
downtime because they're like well I'm
going to fall behind you know or I'm not
going to make the progress that I need
to do but we we really need more
downtime good downtime than we we get
you know
another thing that downtime allows us to
do is to stop and reevaluate things if
we're constantly on the go yeah and
we're we've we've set down a path and
we're you know executing that program of
like these are the things I have to do
XYZ ABC in that order every day must do
these things
um over and over and you never have the
moment to just go oh is this still a
thing I want to do yeah um and if you're
not you know every once in a while doing
that then you're gonna find yourself
years down the road realizing that you
would you know gone 100 miles an hour in
the wrong direction
um and now now you put yourself at a
much worse place than where you wanted
to eventually go yeah that's quite true
and you know I'm guilty of this myself I
I use a Google Calendar that I put all
sorts of things into and the day gets
filled up with I'm gonna do this and I'm
gonna do that and and sometimes it
actually ruins the fun of some of the
activities that I'm involved in I'll be
like well I'm writing from 1 to 3 P.M
and then I feel the pressure to like get
something good done in that time and if
I don't get something good then I I feel
like I'm a loser you know
um but you know I'm the one who's who's
placed all those silly expectations on
myself I mean some of them are
commitments I've made to other people
granted right that I probably shouldn't
have always made but
um a lot of it is uh is self-inflicted
and before I had the Google Calendar I
used to I used to have like a white
board and I would do a tasks for the day
thing and I found myself getting down
because I wouldn't get a lot of them
done and then I would have to shift them
over to the next day and some of them
would just like be on there for five six
days straight you know and when you're
reminded of what you're not getting done
you feel like like crap right ah
so
um slightly tangential but um I got into
bullet journaling at one point in time
now what is that a bullet journal and
it's it's a you know a to-do list with
extra steps and it's it's kind of nice
okay um you know uh basically the main
idea is that every day that you
I actually prefer preferably at least
the day before you put down all the
things that you would like to do
and make little bullets here and you can
you know um cross them off if uh you
don't uh or so once you do them
um but at the end of the day you look at
the things that are left over and you
make a decision before you make your
list for the next day okay
um all the ones that did not get done
are they important and if they're not
important enough that I didn't get them
done yeah are they really actually
important in the first place and can you
just not do them okay so you're giving
yourself permission to drop things off
your list that that's that's a good
practice that's smart
because otherwise uh you just keep
accumulating more and more stuff that
you can get done right
um and then also you know learning how
to say no is also really important yeah
in that regardless that's okay extension
of saying no to yourself is also to
other people around you
I think a long time ago we did a show
about like setting limits right and
sticking to them and that might be a
topic for us to
revisit again
particularly as you know as you noted
we've come out of covid where you know
we people have gone back into the
workplace and there's tenancies for all
sorts of people to to make demands on us
that we probably need to push back on
some time I do want to address a few
questions I I solicited some
input from people in social media and
YouTube when I you know I should have
done it a little bit earlier because I
didn't get as much as I would have liked
but
um you know I I put that we were going
to talk about this topic on the wisdom
for Life show and one person wrote this
is a great topic I'm in the final leg of
the semester and facing burnout once
again this is more of an academic
student one when you were in grad school
did you work seven days a week or take a
day off to recharge and the answer is I
didn't work seven days a week I didn't
even necessarily work six days a week in
grad school you know when I was in grad
school
I was spending until I I actually got
into some some relationships that took a
lot more of my time I was probably
working out about two hours a day
physical exercise and I was like you
know learning languages and stuff like
that and of course reading a lot of
philosophy and doing doing work but I
also partied quite a bit and had time
for like hanging out with friends or
just you know I did some gardening I did
you know I adopted to two kittens and
played with them I think actually pets
are are a great way to spend Leisure
Time
um and you know when I look back on it
well I noticed this right away when I
became a professor you have so much more
time as a graduate student than you do
as a working professor
and that's probably the case in a lot of
jobs right
um but it's I never got bored at that
time and it seemed like there was always
stuff to do
a lot of it was related to the
profession I Was preparing for but a lot
of it wasn't you know digging up uh
spots to put in bulbs so that there'd be
flowers coming up in the spring I mean
that was just kind of screwing off time
for me you know which had some some
useful results or picking flowers or
taking walks or things like that I I you
know I found a lot of time to do that
sort of thing and I know that it was
pretty pretty healthy for me to do that
and similarly
um I remember between undergraduate and
graduate school I lived here in
Milwaukee over on Farwell in a tiny
little studio apartment not far from
shank Hall and I was working two jobs I
I would work in a cafe that no longer
exists and I worked as a third shift
security guard
sometimes with you know no days off
because they were very stingy about
hiring new people and so sometimes we
have to work very very long shifts and
stuff like that and yet I did I did have
a lot of time to kind of screw off and
enjoy myself and get enough sleep and
make make decent meals for myself
sometimes you know you look at the past
and then you look at like where we are
in the present and you say well how did
things get how did they get so busy now
you know and I think there's there's a
point to
um thinking about that you know what you
were mentioning Dan in terms of our
Skinner boxes are mobile technology
that's been pretty game changing you
know in 1994 and 95 when I would walk
the mile and a half from my apartment on
Farwell to 100 East Wisconsin where I
was doing the security job
um I might listen to my Walkman you know
but I I didn't have a phone that I could
pull out of my pocket and look at
Twitter check emails or anything like
that on you know that I was Tethered to
right I mean what do you so I mean
you've been to college and you also have
done a lot of tech and startup work
um what what would be your answer to
this this question
um let's see the first thing is I'd
always take basically a whole day off at
that minimum on right after finals okay
just do like basically nothing I I just
needed that like decompression time
um
uh but otherwise like after right after
college I was working a full-time job
um and then I was uh
I do my my nine to five
um I was working for uh as a system in
for a um super Computing cluster
um and then I I went home I ate dinner
and I rode my bike 10 miles to my
startup job and I worked on that until
about midnight and then I wrote about
hours
um and then a wrench repeats and then I
was also a volunteer house managing for
a um yeah uh a boarding house
um just because I had some Property
Management uh infra or background and I
could help out in that regard and
between those three things I totally
burnt out um I I overextended myself and
um
and it ended badly
um for a number of things including like
relationships um that were associated
with you know some of these Endeavors I
was trying to build
um yeah it you can't go 100 miles all
the time
um things are going to fall through the
cracks and you're not going to be doing
any one thing at the intensity or the
um thoughtfulness that one
ought to do if they're like wanting to
be excellent at the thing that they're
trying to do yeah and that's got
psychological effects when you're doing
subpar work and I I say this from my own
experience of committing to too many
things and being overextended it doesn't
feel good
um you I mean it's one thing if you've
got a job just sweeping floors okay I
mean you can even do that well right
um or in a lackadaisical sort of way but
if you're if other people are depending
on you to like deliver on things that
are kind of complex relax and demand
some thought and attention and you just
kind of half-ass it after a while
if they let you get away with it you
know you know that you're not doing your
best here's here's another interesting
question I'll let you answer this one
okay first uh rather than me jumping in
what is decent downtime Does it include
our favorite activities do our favorite
activities actually relieve stress or
function more as distractions how did
individuals in the past have downtime
what did they do with it
foreign
for me it's it's totally disconnecting
um that that's one of the biggest things
is
um I don't want to uh have to interact
with people
um so if you need to get rid of your
phone for a couple days great if you
need to go to the woods even better
um you know that's uh and sleep sleep
well over sleep uh that that what is
what I consider to be really good
downtime
um and then
um you know have a good close relation
ships that you can go and just be
comfortable with can it be present there
yeah especially if you got family you
can just get those good hugs
all those endorphins that we get from
um being with people that we we really
care about and enjoy the company of
um that's what I would consider I like
that idea of uh being present it reminds
me of a philosopher who I didn't put
into the show notes or anything but this
guy Gabriel Marcel who's understood like
as being an existentialist he he
actually is the first person to use the
term existentialism in French and then
Jean pulsart comes along and kind of
Bogarts the term and he's like yeah you
can have it right and he talks about
availability uh in French disponabilite
as this really Central value so like we
would translate it probably as presence
when when you're with somebody you're
actually like listening to them you're
not you know getting your phone out and
multi tasking or thinking about the work
that you have to do the next day or
something you're actually there with
your family or your friend or your your
romantic partner or whoever else it
happens to be and you can do this even
with strangers that you you know start
chatting with on the bus or in a coffee
house or something like that obviously
it's not going to go quite as deep right
but
um that that does seem to be an
important component of of downtime what
do you think about this this favorite
activities question do our favorite
activities relieve stress or function
more as
distractions does it depend on what the
activity is or who we are
I think it's highly dependent absolutely
um
you know I guess there's
this whole idea about like introverts
versus extroverts okay
um and that seems to be of at least
dubious claim
um in a really easy like dichotomy
um
if there is something to it it's
definitely a long Spectrum but you know
certain people get energized by being in
crowds with people and some people
um it is the opposite and so one needs
to know themselves enough to know what
are the things that are actually
beneficial for them and seek those
things out
um what what may be uh beneficial for
you know just relaxing for me might be
very different from you Greg so for
example I'm not a really big in the
middle and so I think you would much
more enjoy a metal concert than I would
yeah
interestingly I was just thinking about
that so I was able to take my oldest kid
to their first like real battle show at
the Pabst Theater it was wasp and
armored saved
um I mean we we've gone to like stuff at
Summerfest but this is like being in the
theater with a whole bunch of other
people that are like just there to see
this this show and it was a great show
um but I I remember like having this
uptight attitude about shows in the past
and I was much younger and didn't really
have it together like I would go with my
friends and we'd see Iron Maiden or AC
DC or whoever and I needed it to be like
the best experience ever you know and I
would put this kind of
um stress or weight on my shoulders like
I have to be really enjoying myself or
else you know it's not it's not a great
experience and yeah I mean not every
show is going to be great you know
things are going to go wrong I mean one
of the things that actually did go wrong
the that a cat noticed was the singer
and the guitarist for armored Saint
would come out on the wings you know and
the spotlight would be like not on them
so they're in the darkness they're
playing or singing and the spotlight is
on nobody and you know you can let that
sort of thing like ruin your your night
or you could be like up
things something must have gone wrong
there somebody didn't program something
right or somebody's not not paying
attention
um you know with the activities I was
thinking so some activities
some activities are probably not going
to be even if they're your favorite
activity they're not going to be like
good down time like going to the casino
and you know pumping money into slots I
mean some people say they find that
relaxing but
I don't know about that or likes
endlessly binge watching shows on Hulu
or Netflix or you know whatever other
streaming thing that's it's entertaining
but it's it's not it's not as
refreshing and relaxing as as it could
be or maybe some of it would be like you
know you're not really into nature but
somebody drags you along on a you know
five mile hike at one of our we've got
so many parks around here that you know
one could go to
um if that's not your thing then it's
not it's not going to be really good
downtime you know
um I I enjoy just like you know reading
um I will admit that I don't I don't
often just read philosophical books for
fun you know I mean sometimes I go back
to Classics that I know I'm going to
enjoy most of the time if I'm going to
read something for fun it's it's sci-fi
or fantasy or horror or something like
that you know
so I'm right with you I do a a regular
palette cleanser I'll I'll read
something that's uh fiction and then
I'll try to find something non-fiction
kind of go back and forth yeah I I have
a former client who became a friend
who's who's a really good reader I mean
he he just like blazes through books and
he he talks about it in terms of the
broccoli and the dessert you know He
makes himself read half an hour or
something that he feels that he ought to
read for his benefit you know and then
he gets to read what he wants to read
you know so now I like broccoli so
yeah same here yeah but
uh
so what else we got we got as some
diatribes into some Asian philosophy
here yeah I mean I think that philosophy
is a way of life
um and there's a lot of different
schools of it have some useful
considerations for us on these matters
um you know ancient philosophers okay
they weren't living in the kind of
situation that we are they tended to be
kind of you know they were they're part
of Elites they thought that people who
worked with their hands were really
living a crappy life
um Aristotle looks down on them for
example and
um
you know they they had some pretty clear
ideas about what kind of life was a a
life that was
fully human that we might reject in part
but they they did think that Leisure was
important not just for philosophy but
for any sort of good life in in general
and you know Aristotle provides us with
a framework for thinking about the kind
of life that we want to live so what we
call a teleology or an orientation
towards goals and a lot of the his ideas
translate very well to today you've got
lives that are devoted to making money
like the guy that we started out talking
about at the beginning
and Aristotle calls it a life of
compulsion you know but he thinks that
some people can start viewing that as
like the goal in itself just accumulate
as much money or wealth or whatever it's
going to be as you can
um then you know some people are devoted
to just enjoying as many Pleasures as
they can these are the people who say oh
if I won the lottery I'd never work
another day in my life I would just like
go on cruises and enjoy myself and you
know you notice that it doesn't really
work out that way for a lot of lottery
winners their life tends to be kind of
shallow and and empty when they actually
get everything that they want and then
he also talks about the life pursuing
honor or you know positions Prestige
that kind of thing and he says that
that's also it's good but it's kind of
hollow and then he proposes two lives as
the good life one is the life of
contemplation or theoria the word we get
Theory from and you know it's it's funny
because a lot of people think that they
imagine to themselves that the life of
the academic is like that most academics
these days are not living a life of
contemplation and Terror yeah they're
they're having to do all sorts of
administrative tasks and worrying about
whether they're going to get fired in a
couple years or stuff like that but the
other life that he talks about that I
myself am actually much more attracted
to is the life that is devoted to
virtuous activity and this could this
doesn't have to be you know virtuous
activity with the exact list that
Aristotle has or you know the four
cardinal virtues that the stoics and the
platonists recognized I mean I think
that you can have a career where you're
making some sort of contribution to
people's lives and that's that's a life
of virtuous activity or the life of
taking care of other people is the life
of virtuous activity a meaningful life
where you're you're actually doing some
some good things but even those lives
you need some down time some socializing
some relaxation some as he calls them
amusements or play p idea the word for
for uh the kind of play that that kids
do right and Aristotle thinks that this
is uh this is something valuable it's
not like the whole goal of life but we
need it and if we deprive ourselves of
it we're cutting ourselves off from the
good life you could say I mean what do
you make of that that idea
so
like do we need to be the the relaxation
that comes with play you know just just
screwing around you know I think part of
that especially from like a
virtue ethic point of view is that
um a lot of time like our play is with
others
um and so there is a
um a duty that one has especially to
their friends if you want to have
friends or things that you do with them
in order to Foster and nurture those
relationships and if you're not doing
those things and you're not being a
really good friend and so it requires
you to have you know some of these you
know frivolous relaxing times with these
people in order to be good at being a
friend with them
yeah that makes sense
um
sometimes I use as an example how can
you tell who your friends are well
they're the ones who if they have a
truck will help you move right but it
can't all be helping you move sometimes
it has to be the pizza party after that
and having having a six-pack of beers
and sitting around and chewing the fat
you know right I mean and it could
include things that otherwise might be
you know distractions like like sitting
and watching a show together
um I mean if all you're doing is
watching show after show after show
maybe that's not good but doing it with
another person and laughing at the same
stuff and
discussing it afterwards exactly yeah
yeah we're stopping the discussion
midpoint and then you never actually get
back to the thing that you're watching
the point in the first place because not
every friend's gonna be cool with that
oh but but like I'm just kind of like
there's there's been a number of times
in my life where
it is at the the conversation has been
such a better use of our time so we both
realized it at the moment that okay the
the media whatever we are watching uh
takes a major back seat that the
um
that this interaction is is the much
more valuable thing
that's yeah that's true and and it needs
to be something that isn't like rigidly
scheduled right or there's not a
checklist for how to have a good
interaction or something like that I I
didn't hit all the box I didn't have a
good time yeah I don't know you know the
the stoics I think also have some useful
things to contribute and and the stoics
are are interesting because as opposed
to like the platoness or the
aristotelians where you know you've got
all the you're you're essentially in the
rich class and you don't have to work
and you study philosophy quite a few of
the stoic philosophers had day jobs you
know clanthis was a water carrier
um Epictetus runs a school but starts
himself out as a slave and you know
eventually is is teaching people and
having conversations Marcus Aurelius of
course is stuck with the in some
respects the best and the worst job of
all uh emperor of the entire Roman
Empire here which man I would not want
that job
heavy they had the where's the crown
yeah and but you know they they
um
I think they some of the things that
they have to contribute is reminding us
that we don't want to be too wrapped up
with what they called indifference or
externals and wealth is one of those our
social position you know we we don't
want to be too anxious about that stuff
so that when we actually have free time
we're constantly worried or obsessed or
comparing ourselves to other people you
know that's that's not particularly
helpful
Epictetus interestingly actually has a
whole chapter in his discourses about
people who make
relaxation or peace or free time their
primary goal and they they sort of
structure their life around that and he
says that that can even
turn into a trap
um because you get too attached to it
you need to learn how to like roll with
um
what you're dealt and find the the spots
where you can
take a breather and relax and then get
back to what it is that you need to do
um
one other thing I would mention too
Seneca has this book called on shortness
of life and it's a good reminder right
because I mean we could die tomorrow
um but how can we have
um a good life I mean he's going to
frame it in terms of philosophy he says
those uh only the people who give their
life to philosophy are at leisure only
they truly live it's not just their own
lifetime they watch over carefully they
take on every age to their own all the
years that have gone before are added to
their own now when you say it that way
it could it doesn't have to be
philosophy it could be history it could
be
um thinking about whatever discipline
you're involved with so he he uses the
example of like we can dispute with
Socrates entertain doubt with carniadics
who's a skeptic be at peace with
epicurus overcome human nature with the
stoics go beyond it with the cynics and
we can do this reading Seneca we can or
we can also do this reading great
literature
um you know I'm going to teaching for
example Mary Shelley's Frankenstein next
semester I'm looking forward to getting
to read it again and share it with
undergraduates who probably had to read
it in high school as an assigned text
and we're going to reread it and you
know like actually pay attention to
what's going on in it and uh I know the
last time that I read Frankenstein I
really enjoyed it you know so you know I
think the stoics would be cool with us
finding the things that we derive real
enjoyment real
refreshment from and incorporating that
not in a like self-indulgent way but in
a way that recognizes that we we human
beings do need downtime
um
you know and maybe for not everybody
needs to do philosophy
um
could be other things instead
yeah I like this idea of like you know
the the literature you know there's a
off-quoted like what a a man lives but
one life but a man who reads lives a
thousand that we get this this greater
perspective of the world and once again
this kind of comes back to the idea that
I put forward earlier about what we
actually want in our lives if we are so
you know uh cloistered that we don't
know any of the other options that are
potentially available to us and we can
never make a really fully well-informed
decision about what we want to pursue in
our own lives
um
yeah
I really do
um like in here with the Stokes so like
it's very practical
um and specifically that it's not
something that you have to have money
and time to be you know in your maybe
the Epicurean Walled Garden
um that yeah
um this is something that you do as part
of life uh
you know and and people can become uh
too attached to being like the best
stoic they can possibly be or the best
Aristotelian or pick whatever else you
want right and not recognize that hey
these things take a lot of time and uh
even Epictetus says hey I'm never going
to be Socrates but at least I can be a
decent Epictetus you know he was placing
Socrates above him in the ordering of
like I guess great philosophers and I
don't even need to be an Epictetus it's
enough for me to be a decent uh
instructor and writer and you know do a
radio show like this and
yeah that sort of thing right right
um yeah like the you know comparison is
the thief of uh happiness as an idea
here that um you know comparing
yourselves to others is going to make
you unhappy but comparing yourself to
the person you were yesterday can you
just be a little bit better than that
and and maybe you don't even have to be
better than that just tread water
because sometimes you just need to relax
and
um and keep that afloat yeah I think
that's a really important recognition
um I mean we have this phrase don't let
the best be the enemy the good right and
what's important in there is recognizing
that if we even if we are just like
staying where we are and as you say
Treading Water that's still a good it's
still an achievement you know
um you may not be getting to I don't
know whatever Crystal Palace you're
trying to establish you know down the
line
um to use just one of the many metaphors
that we could we could have but it's
it's still an accomplishment it's still
something you know there is one other
person I wanted to bring up
um
Lorena Maria rilka this this German
language poet
uh also a novelist letter writer he
wrote this this work that I I like a lot
called letter letters to or yeah letters
to a young poet
um which often gets used like there's
also letters to a young Chef by by a
culinary guy there's letters to a young
philosopher out there but rilka was a
poet and he had this guy who wrote him
and he like sent rilke some poems and
he's like hey can you check my poems out
and tell me whether they're any good and
rilka says oh they're not very good but
let me tell you kid and he gives him a
whole bunch of advice and one of the
terms that he brings up over and over
and over again we translate it as
Solitude in German it's einzan kite
which literally means being on your own
and being on your own can sometimes be
lonely but it's also rilka thinks really
important and we need to be able to
cultivate this like not not being uh
involved and things just sort of like
paying attention to what's there it
could be what's there in our memories of
our childhood it could be like paying
attention to the natural world that
we're involved in it could be paying
attention to
um you know how your body feels after
you do a workout it could be anything
you want and it can also involve other
people and interestingly for a rilca
Solitude is something that you can
cultivate even in crowds so you could be
in the coffee house with everybody else
around you doing stuff and you're just
cultivating your Solitude
um and he thinks that this is important
for us this this like not detaching from
the world but like opening ourselves up
to a deeper dimension of it
um and it actually is important for even
romantic relationships he's got this
wonderful phrase that I love he says for
one human being to love another that is
perhaps the most difficult of all of our
tasks he's probably right about that the
ultimate last test in proof the work for
which all other work is but preparation
I hold this to be the highest task for a
bond between two people uh two solitudes
Each of which protects the other so you
know you take the the person who's been
able to develop and can be on their own
and
um you put them together with another
person like that not just like giving in
to Convention not just like trying to
you know have a hook up and and get it
on or something like that but actually
like and this could be friendship this
could be love this could be all sorts of
things but two solitudes that recognize
and and protect each other because
they've cultivated that within
themselves I think that's I mean is that
the same thing as downtime no but I
think it's adjacent to it
you know what do you make of that
does that resonate with you or
a bit
um I don't know if I've
fully groked this to be
I don't know there's definitely
something along the lines of being able
to be with a person without directly
interacting to be just in the same space
and be kind of comfortable therein yeah
not having to chatter right yeah so just
like oh well you're going to read a book
and I'm going to read a book and we're
going to be in close proximity and we
might have some tea but there's no need
for us to directly interact but just the
the presence of another person that you
um
have this strong relationship with
do you think that could extend to our
relationships with animals like our pets
as well
depends on how needy your pet is
your cat or dog is like give me pets
give me pets give me pets
that's true yeah yeah there are some
pets where Maybe
they would constantly be bugging you uh
for attention right but yeah I think in
general lots of times you know it's just
nice to have a cat sitting and purring
on your lap and you're reading a book or
something and or the dog is just curled
up next to you and it's just a you know
presence
yeah that's that's that's a great way to
put it and maybe
we provide that to other people too if
we're not like too needy
in um how we're using our Leisure Time
how we're using our downtime right right
so okay we assume we have a practice
here
um so saying no can you go deeper into
that correct I think this is a very
quick one
um say no to something you would
ordinarily say yes to and then use that
time and use it to do nothing
nothing try to do nothing you know what
is this nothing yeah I mean you have to
like just like sit there but just don't
try to make it productive
um
try out and see what happens with that
but we're getting really close to the
end of the the time yeah do you want to
lead us out with a final thought yeah so
we have our uh final words from Bertrand
Russell a great deal of harm is being
done in the world by belief in the
virtuousness of work the road to
happiness and prosperity lies in and
organized diminution of work
thank you
[Music]